welcome to this video casablanca from
denmark classical a thread let's see
okay it's doing for the the Steinitz
line yeah a 6b five recently examined in
this already mentioned put poem or God
and until this v6 is strange i think it
is only played after yeah you know
usually you cannot cast along here
because of c-4 now i'm a hoe temple down
my butt suppress the good probably yeah
cannot not not you shouldn't waste any
time you have just fire fire way okay if
he goes 96 I'm not going to take it this
is my castle first so that I can
actually tolerate the 99 group p8 just
going on the be line on the B file yeah
this is always always a problem for for
what an interesting move
hmm
hmm yeah 96 really ok on night d 6 if he
goes 96 now I will play C 3 ok he's
taking first I can check HERE 96
Macrinus really away from the action I
cannot do that ok i am he has b3 as a
defense
oh it couldn't be six for example I can
play b3 to stop it I don't really see
how to play this with the NOI daddy 6
cyl on the board I need to fight against
the peace and now my ideas might be six
to eight for something like that yeah
this wasn't really intended in this in
this particular manner but it looks like
dangerous
ok let's go ahead one ideas night a4 be
3c three which would be a I think deadly
brilliant you know so let's try to go
towards yeah this is I expect it and I
hope that there still would be some
plain but how how exactly Bishop d7 days
you can maybe even take
hmm
maybe this one Bishop d7 night then move
the night this is all so intense III if
appropriate
maybe I should just play rook fa to see
it just get the rook back yeah g4 only
help me with that not not sure about
that but maybe this is some good defense
so so now the c3 I'm not really helping
ok let's let's open an open the position
up and now see to what what I can do the
queen is really a pest here it should be
82 g6 my idea
mmm kd6 is not not too bad square we
already saw that before I can't simply
cannot get rid of this bloody queen
see even got Bishop b5 which looks
really problematic what the heck yeah
the Queen on 85 what a great defense of
peace I can just take see it he can and
should take the eight and then maybe
maybe he's got something better but it's
it's it's clearly a good move mmhmm yeah
I don't I don't I don't have anything
radium maybe night would be five or
something the night on b6 just lousy
drying that time for them now from
trading Queens is not really helping
night see form not the greatest idea
ever or the most sophisticated let's put
it that way now but also night a form
it's not so easy what is he doing now
time Barney takes rook takes I've got
Luke a for coming maybe this is shocking
him and the screen a5 threatened this is
maybe a good practical chance check
mmm very good defense didn't I didn't
see Jagan check check check I'm Joshua
second son he was like he was one heads
aren't I even lost one or two moose ago
but ok I just was I was so down on time
and he you really caught up now the
Queen FF I can't just play Queen 85
instead of my fancy move like c4 yeah
just grab the rook yeah it was clear
that he was a bit struggling in this
position but ok this is this is also
winning of course again nidoqueen a5 I
forgot about that and this is a cool
check defense Quincy for is still good
yeah ok I didn't have any time here d 4
yeah this is very easy but i only have
six second son's really makes the
easiest things difficult Adam I'm
Anderson I watch it I want to check the
opening quickly I think I played a
plague be 6 too early 11 move too early
it's still probably probably interesting
but the 96 idea makes this son ok I
missed a very important point here i can
i can do that and the idea jack is after
that that I have Knight f6 to your phone
yes I've actually seen this idea before
but I forgot it yeah this is a very good
position
like the computer only says is equal but
this is a matter of time until it
changes evaluations this is very good
for black I get the night to e4 and this
is among I'm a temple down compared to
an online because I play b6 and d5 there
is this just to make clear what I want
me to do this there's this line which is
very good for black they are almost
winning this line actually this tech is
super dangerous and in this line we have
the same motif but now I'm a temple down
in the game continuation but it's still
interesting and i played this very well
until they faltered went I'm gonna know
around TM I mean yeah this is probably
bad Queen fif was excellent really
stopping all kinds of counter play maybe
is this one and this this this kind of
stuff I mean I still have a line open we
should be 72 to g6 yeah I didn't really
play with the amp while I had a plan
night to a 4 but Queen a 5 was very very
strong the sweetest stops everything in
its tracks I mean not even slightest
idea that i have him okay interesting
thanks for watching